Je pensais que
je ne pourrais pas diriger ce club pour toujours.
Je l'ai construit pour rien.
C'est ma famille,
toi et moi, gamin
[Musique]
depuis le début,
oui s'il vous plaît,
c'était l'âge d'or des cyclistes et je
ne me suis jamais senti aussi à ma place.  toute ma
vie,
c'est là que je l'ai vu pour la première fois,
j'ai coupé le souffle
[Musique]
plus tard dans le Maryland,
j'ai pensé que je pouvais le changer, tu sais,
pas pour être différent, mais pour l'être,
je ne sais pas comme s'il était sauvage,
hé, je te l'ai dit.  pour enlever cette veste,
tu devrais tuer
[Musique] et
le bar
Ney en bas,
le club est devenu très gros, très vite, ils ont
commencé à faire de la drogue, du jeu, de la
prostitution, j'ai dit que je voulais ce club,
maintenant
tu arrêtes de rouler,
je ne peux pas avoir  eux, s'il veut faire du
vélo,
tu fais du vélo,
réfléchis-y, tu sais,
étranger